this is like I mean I've give I've had
three children
that's crazy yeah
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Kate Hudson she's
an Academy Award nominated actress and
entrepreneur with a portfolio that
includes everything from King Street
vodka to her beauty and wellness
products within Bloom you can also catch
her in the long-weighted follow-up film
Glass Onion and knives out mystery which
will be available globally on Netflix
December 23rd Kate Hudson welcome to the
show thank you I'm excited scared you're
a little scared nervous exciting around
spicy food before we get started
terrible terrible I I'm I'm I'm probably
gonna be one of your worst spice
Pips
um
I don't recognize any of these and
that's because I don't I don't even have
them in my house
well it's time to explore the world you
know explore this and I hope I can get
through it I'm gonna try my best I'm
gonna try my best my kids will be proud
of me of course that's all we can ask
are you ready to get started sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh God this is gonna be the real test of
my abilities
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
that feels pretty good there you go yeah
so I want to start by complimenting the
film I actually love the knives out
movies Glass Onion in particular as I
think they scratch an itch that has
otherwise been kind of neglected by
Hollywood yeah what did you mean when
you said we need more movies like this
and I'm just so grateful I get to be in
this one well I think that the theater
going movie is new this new theater
going experience is dying you know I
mean our our industry is hurting there
and it's movies like Glass Onion that
bring me hope that maybe we can
reinvigorate not only the theater going
experience but people taking chances on
what is a crowd-pleasing film because
it's one thing if it's Marvel you know
you're going to get that event movie but
to go in and have a completely different
movie experience something that isn't in
that world is so important to our
industry
thank you
hello Dodge heading a little harder
this is Lippy yeah this is a Lippy yeah
it definitely feels like you know I'm
like those plump plump lip glosses
um that all Us Girls love Yeah free
treatment right that's right right here
did you see my lips after the hot one
how if it all did work in an
apprenticeship at the Williamstown
theater Festival of Massachusetts how
did that shape your appreciation for
acting oh I love that question you know
when I was
I was still in high school and my mom
was like you're too boy crazy
I'm shipping you off
to Williamstown theater Festival and I
was like what
no you know it's like that age where all
you want to do is be with your friends
and I loved working on my craft but like
that was dedicated for this school year
like this is my summer you know I had no
idea what it was I didn't know what she
had uh signed me up for my mom had
actually given me my Independence as a
young artist and discovering what that
is and that was it was just the greatest
experience of my teenage your mom was
right she was so right do you remember
your literal like first ever production
like what was on the Marquee outside the
Santa Monica playhouse in the early 90s
the first time I was ever on stage I was
a little girl I played little Alice in
Allison
Alice and I do remember my mom saying
she's never seen anything bigger in her
life than that little Alice I led with
my chest
he was like it was like all chess you
know
[Music]
what if I'm great at this
what if I'm like the best person you've
ever had on this I think that's where
this is going really I don't think so I
think so I can see it I can see it
already this is interesting mm-hmm
that maybe my kids have prepared me for
this a little bit because they do make
me try things yeah yeah like really
aggressive spice I was talking to Bing
before this started yeah you know he's
he's young but it seems like he's
started oh no he is one of them I have
to be like okay
no she just can't be good for your
stomach lining we're still developing
bingo
is it true that during production for
nine Daniel Day-Lewis would send you
notes on custom stationery from the
perspective of his character Guido yes
from Guido
it was the best and I remember you know
I had the best of Daniel I remember
um
Leonardo DiCaprio saying to me not to
drop anything drop that uh but Leo said
to me once like how is Daniel you know
and I was like ah the best he's like
really and I was like oh yeah you had
him on Gangs of New York I was like you
got that Daniel I got Guido you know I
mean it was like the juxtaposition of
like you know your arch nemesis who's
trying to kill you versus the man who's
trying to sleep with you are two very
different Daniel method actors and yeah
he would I would get I would show up to
my dressing room and have notes
um from Guido you know Stephanie you
were wonderful yesterday you know I was
like
it's like when I die my children are
gonna like this is my grandchildren this
is this might this might this might live
on you know we'll live on we'll live if
I can find them
thank you
[Music]
Los Calientes
foreign
I like this one I actually really like
this one wow is that weird no we
actually make it so I love that oh
really is this yours oh my God it is hot
ones
so that's why I was just that's why I
was just soaking it it's got a little
sweet in there yeah but it's like this
is this is
look how good you're doing look how sell
your product right now there we go it
does have the perfect
space yeah and it's a little sweet and
it's got It's good this is good
so when you launched your craft vodka
line King Street vodka you called it the
most on-brand business you've ever done
do you have a signature cocktail for the
holidays and if so can you talk us
through how to make it
I made just recently what I'm calling a
Goldie's Mad Dash oh this sounds good
I made a lychee martini and I did two
ounces vodka two ounces lychee
an ounce of the cranberry and then I did
a dash of orange bitters that sounds
nice and it's so good and something my
mom loves so I called it Goldie's Mad
Dash which also is her personality I
just love a good drink and in the winter
I love my I love my bourbons and I'll
have a whiskey yeah you know me too the
fire the Cozy by the fire drink
[Music]
this one looks ominous
I think the texture is not my favorite
yeah it was just a little too oily
but if I was eating pizza oh I might
like that
what is going on
I'm five in
and it's like yeah I haven't even
touched my milkshake
yeah I know I've noticed I've noticed
you haven't touched the milkshake am I
pregnant
hold on a second does anyone have my
flow calendar
this is weirding me out just I think you
know you just set the bar too low okay
crazy in a second is what you're saying
I'm not gonna lie to you okay
got it okay but in the meantime we have
a recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram we do a deep dive on
our Gus and scramble interesting
pictures that need more contact so we'll
pull the picture up over here on the
monitor okay and you just tell us the
big bigger story okay how big a thrill
was it for you to share a mic live and
uncomfortable of my life that was the
best moment ever
you know what sometimes when I'm feeling
low I like go I Google that picture I'm
like Kate Hudson Bruce Springsteen you
know like just the fact that I can
Google those two names together and that
comes up is like it's like I could you
know I've it's like that's it you know
I've died and gone to heaven
I did this I did a show where I
presented
um it was a charity function
and at the end everybody was supposed to
go out on a stage and like Sing Don't
Stop Believing you know
I'm kind of singing to myself and Bruce
I see him it was like out of the it was
like out of the Courtney Cox
um it was like yeah music video Yeah he
was like
and I kind of like
me I was like is he pointing at me and
he was casting
and I was just like I am not gonna shy
yeah if Bruce asks I shall arrive yes
you know and and uh and he just brought
me on the mic and we started singing
together and I was like I literally got
in the car and I like welled up like
because it was just so it was just
amazing that was just the best I'm such
a huge huge fan of his so that was
pretty awesome
[Music]
love turmeric you like it
anti-inflammatory
is still like it
[Music]
definitely
yeah definitely new level
has some like sharp edges I feel like
with this exactly
but it's not together
like the hip oh [ __ ] you want to know
what I did once what
I went to China
for Kung Fu Panda
and they sent me to Chengdu which never
in my life
if you showed me where Chang do
I like it though it's like clearing
I'm in Chengdu visiting the pandas and
it's the Szechuan place I think it's
Szechuan so we went and had
this is really
this has heat now I know where we're
going yeah yeah whoa
um oh and and it's it's like that it
like keeps going waves right yeah
when you went to China what was the
culinary highlight I had a tofu dish
there that I still think about
you know yeah well I always like when
I'm following you I kind of that's what
I kind of pay attention to it's like you
had that like Tokyo trip where you were
like having breakfast with sumo
wrestlers yes takazawa doing like
tasting menus I love tacos yeah
I love food yeah I mean and I'm one of
those that takes pictures of it I like I
could do I sometimes I'm like you know
in another
like life of mine somewhere in my head I
am doing a food blog as well you know I
could just travel the world I want to
travel the world doing a food show that
would be the most fun ever well hey
let's talk afterwards yeah
[Music]
the cosmic disco sounds like somewhere
I've been before
let's do this
right away yeah right away yeah and it
has kind of like a sweet barbecue thing
like a little bit up front but yeah it
hits so hard yeah not great just a beat
later yeah this actually my favorite one
remember when I told you about
the throat scratch yeah and you're like
oh this look at that throat scratch like
this is such a throat scratch this is
what happens at this Cosmic disco that
didn't happen at the one that I went to
wow it's called karma sauce yeah because
it's [ __ ] hot mm-hmm
oh Catherine Han would say [ __ ] hot
did you really eat that I did I did I'm
right along with you over here I know
wow oh my God how fun
[Music]
I'm gonna stay so positive you're not
even gonna know what
how that happens
okay
so we had your How to Lose a Guy in
Fool's Gold co-star Matthew McConaughey
on the show oh how is he with this am I
beating him you are you're doing it all
I care about I want to take Matthew down
on this one no I bet he was great he
talked about the Hallmarks of a good
romantic Colony what to you
distinguishes a good rom-com from a
mediocre one
an actually good story I mean let's
start with that like I think that
sometimes people think rom-coms are all
about that kind of
[Applause]
the meek here
hold on let's have a conversation like
this
um
I feel like it's like
um a great rom-com
it's about meeting love discovering love
falling in love love falling apart and
then how you come back together that's a
very traditional rom-com structure
the ones that we love are like two movie
stars
and a love story and that you know that
that they're shiny and they're bright
and they are they they are it's like
wish fulfillment and it's supposed to
make you feel fuzzy
and then they stay with you forever
they're the most classic
[Music]
um but just because they're supposed to
feel bright doesn't mean they need to
look so bright so you know a lot of
times I think that again the genre gets
kind of dumbed down
because they think they know
and then the chemistry you know so I'm
grateful that it was me and Matthew
because he is a blast
I feel like I'm really winning at this
dissertation thank you and like it's the
class I'm gonna be at NYU film school
and when I'm 75
I'll be uh the professor of rom-coms
de bomb Beyond insanity
[Music]
and that's just kind of like immediately
foreign
wow it's a different level all together
I'm so sad
I've had three children
that's crazy yeah and then just be
careful around the eyes you know yeah
you touch that yeah
um
what about my nose
okay
so we mentioned your beauty and wellness
company in bloom in the intro
for the uninitiated like me like what
are adaptogens and nootropics like how
would you even explain that to like a
dummy like me right now
wow
[Music]
this does this ever
does it end it does like
oh immediately immediately like huh you
know like as bad as you're feeling right
now it's Just Gonna Get Easier from here
you know what I mean like the worst is
kind of over with every passing second
wow
you go up how do I look amazing amazing
it's just like this is what I look like
if we got in a fight
I'm like it's okay it's okay
let's say I'm hosting this show in 25
years like is there a way for me to do
this show but like I want to look like
Rob Lowe you know what I mean when I'm
doing it every man that's what I'm
saying Rob Lowe
well it depends on what you need and
what you want the skin beauty Aura
collagen we loaded it with vitamin C and
that helps the collagen absorb
the come down is interesting it's like
[Music]
a bad [ __ ]
you know not that I've ever had one
son
okay
I'm going in
[Music]
okay
yeah yeah here it comes
but it's really nice right especially
compared to the last one
I feel like I can't feel anything
anymore yeah you're not it's just all
scorching is it just numb not right
it's supposed to be getting worse you're
good you're good don't take yourself out
like as you've survived you're doing
good
I'm [ __ ] killing it you're crushing
it I told you this whole time
I know you are I know but you should be
very proud you're so brave coming in
here thinking
that's what you said you all but
guaranteed it to me but here you are
look at that
it's on the sibling revelry podcast you
and your brother Oliver explore sibling
bonds and family Dynamics with other
siblings and I actually hired my brother
Gavin to help out with the research on
this show do you have any foundational
advice on how to maintain a working
relationship with a sibling yeah don't
work with them
I honestly all on all like all like
just now that I've
buried your soul and yeah born again
like opened up
um
it that has been one of the most
rewarding working experiences I've ever
had and I wouldn't
oh just
somehow regurgitated
you know yeah
and into your life yeah
um
you think you know your sibling those
times I have with Oliver it's brought us
so much closer I also
find it really hard when you're
interviewing people and they don't have
that sibling relationship they have that
fraught they long they long to be close
to their sibling and even when they've
had to heal it or even when they've had
to realize that it's not good for them
and they can't be in that relationship
and they've had to heal that they still
like write in and tell us how important
it is for them to hear a good
relationship with a sibling you know
love that yeah oh [ __ ] what are you
doing this is yours where is this going
are you pouring it on yours
[Music]
the last dab the last day
this is gonna be brutal
blast tap
is that too much no no that's good
that's good that's good okay
Cheers Cheers Kate cheers this has been
an absolute pleasure and a blast knowing
you my last bite my last meal
I am what what is happening I'm amazed
I'm aghast I'm humbled across the table
all right Kate Hudson we've reached the
end we are at the end I promise it is
all almost over I know look at you what
just happened you're no selling you're
no selling the last dab are you so proud
of me right now look at the big smile I
can't believe this look at that smile
I'm shocked at myself
I'm not I knew you know when you said
you couldn't I was here to say that you
could and that you would right and it
does kind of you know have that heat
thing but you know what
you've already eaten it you're it's done
you've conquered the gauntlet and just
one more little hurdle before we roll
credits on this show there's quite close
things out just a question I'm not gonna
bring out any more wings okay but I want
to close with a quote that you said
about one of your most iconic characters
Penny Lane from Almost Famous you said I
like characters who can cry and laugh at
the same time can you unpackage what you
meant by that while your brain and mouth
slow roast in hot sauce
you mean what I did what I did on the
show
would you just witnessed
um
it's like life is beautiful
favorite movie
to be able to laugh through tragedy find
that life force
and sadness
flaw's gold there's a c they're the
beginning when you see me in Fool's Gold
I'm I'm crying laughing in a mirror
I'm kind of taking everything out and
I'm doing it and like I couldn't wait to
do that scene
you know it's the it was challenging
those aren't easy things to do and so
that's fun as an actor when you get
those opportunities
well look at you Kate Hudson walked in
here said I'm gonna be the worst guest
you've ever had on the show walk out dab
in the last wing and taking a bow no
there's nothing left to do that carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
um
yes I am uh listen I hope you guys all
saw the Glass Onion uh a Knives Out
mystery in theaters this past weekend
and week
um but if you haven't it's coming out on
Netflix December 23rd and I can't wait
for you to see it because it's a total
blast
[Applause]
it's so much fun
[Applause]
you did it I did it
I can't believe it
this is
the only thing I'm ever gonna have
bragging rights about it's like you know
it's like this is it this is it I made
it through
can you believe it honey do you want to
try the de bomb
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and I have an important announcement to
all the mini spice Lords out there and
those of us who like to just dabble on
the fringes of spiced them say hello to
our newest flavor from hot ones Jr it's
the red the red takes things up a notch
with ghost pepper and red carrot it
brings a warming Zing to all of your
favorite foods try it on gooey mac and
cheese this winter and thank me later to
get your hands on the hot ones junior
family of sauces visit heatness.com
that's heatness.com heatness.com red
light yellow light green light go now